Good
morning. We are back
live. The plan for
today, I've got an hour and a half,
little less, right now, uh, in which I
want to check over some of the
experiments, launch some new
ones, and nail down a few a few things
there. Uh, generally today, we've got
two different environments. We want to
have solid sweeps running
on maybe
more. We want to check in with Spencer
on the driving sim
results. Uh but generally I think today
is going to be a pretty good day to just
like really get the trainer into a good
spot. Like really just go through and do
all the small little changes here and
there. I think that's what we're going
to want to do.
And the goal here will be if I can be
done with this before Saturday, that
will be
ideal. Let me just switch over the
view
not. We have here
sweeps that are still
going. Uh, I think we want to just
see what results we've gotten so far.
Okay, we have 159 meta
experiments. That's pretty
good. Yeah, that's pretty good.
good? I think we're good. But hang on. I
have to see if it actually reconnects on
X.